but first we begin with what's next
after the killing of ayman al-zwahiri
the leader of al-qaeda azwahiri a key
figure in planning the 9 11 attacks died
in a u.s drone strike in afghanistan on
saturday he'd been running al-qaeda
since osama bin laden was killed and led
the terror organization spread to other
countries president biden announced the
news from the white house last night he
said he hopes this would help bring some
closure senior investigative
correspondent katherine herridge is at
the pentagon with more on how exactly
the u.s finally tracked down al-swahiri
katherine good morning
good morning jerica up until a few
months ago the al-qaeda leader's
location was a huge mystery for u.s
intelligence even with a 25 million
dollar bounty on his head now with this
drone strike senior al qaeda leaders
behind 9 11 are either dead or captured
justice has been delivered and this
terrorist leader is no more president
biden approved the precision strike that
killed al qaeda leader ayman al-zawahiri
two hellfire missiles from a u.s drone
killed azrahiri on the balcony of his
hideout in downtown kabul in afghanistan
the mission was a success
none of his family members were hurt and
there were no civilian casualties the
terrorist leader was tracked down
earlier this year in the busy afghan
capital of kabul where he moved to
reunite with family i gave the final
approval to go get him mr biden said the
successful operation could help close a
final chapter of the 9 11 attacks which
killed nearly 3 000 americans 21 years
ago next month al-swahiri was pivotal to
planning the attack it's my hope that
this decisive action will bring one more
measure of closure al-zwahiri also
played a role in al-qaeda attacks that
murdered americans overseas at two u.s
embassies in east africa and on the uss
coal in yemen after navy seals raided
this compound in pakistan 11 years ago
killing al-qaeda founder osama bin laden
as wahiri took over and for years rumors
about his death swirled his location
unknown
after last year's chaotic withdrawal of
u.s forces from afghanistan mr biden
insisted the weekend strike shows the
u.s ability to target terrorists remains
strong no matter how long it takes
no matter where you hide
if you are a threat to our people the
united states will find you and take you
out
a former senior u.s military official
who ran counter-terrorism operations
told cbs news the question now is how
the al qaeda leader could be living in
the afghan capital without the support
of the taliban indicating the
relationship between al qaeda and the
taliban is as strong as ever nate
catherine thank you